[Music]
in our series a more perfect union we
highlight examples of people coming
together to show
that what unites us is far greater than
what divides us
in texas countless people have
demonstrated extraordinary acts of
humanity to help flood victims
david begnot introduces us to a
furniture store owner who opened his
doors to hundreds of evacuees
david is in the flooded community of
humble just outside houston
good morning margaret good morning a
story that'll
make you smile we all need a smile right
you mentioned this guy's name and
everybody here in houston says oh yeah
mattress mac
guys got a 160 000 foot
showroom huge and at the start of the
storm
he was rescuing people the only
difference with his rescuing
he had a place to take them to
i'm part capitalist and part social
worker and that's what i like to do
everything going right yes sir you need
anything no sir
jim mcinvale aka mattress mac has made a
name for himself selling furniture
but it's his legacy of giving that's
going to leave a permanent impression
i'm worried about these people i'm
worried about the business i'm worried
about the community
sunday he posted via social media that
two of his gallery furniture stores
would be open
not for business but to provide shelter
and food for people in need
valencia grace and her son jalen are now
among the hundreds of people
who've taken up shelter in one of mac's
stores it's good to be here
away from the flood because it would
have got
when it started raining it would have
got all the way right here the water
started to come in the house and it was
coming in so fast we had a matter of
time
to get out the house grace and her son
got in one of the trucks that mack
deployed to rescue people from the
rising flood water
he's also providing food breakfast lunch
and dinner for the evacuees
we thank mr mack for opening up his
doors to us
because we didn't know where our next
meal was going to come from our clothes
on our back
mack estimates it costs 30 or 40
thousand dollars to keep his stores up
and running through the crisis
we can afford that and what we can't
afford is to
cause these people to lose hope we got
to give them hope this is what my
parents would have done
his record of community service would
make his family proud
every christmas his business has
provided furniture to families in need
he also donates his furniture to
makeover teachers lounges and area
schools
it's a long way from new orleans even
providing refuge
isn't new to mack in 2005 he housed 200
of the hurricane katrina evacuees in his
store several of the katrina victims
like jerry burke
even landed a job there you need
anything you got o5 katrina blew me in
lost everything didn't know where i was
going to go
what to do and i came here
and talked to mac and sent me to hr and
the rest was history
he furnished my apartment gave me
everything that i needed
to survive plus a job totally
life-changing for me and my family
some of harvey's evacuees like roberta
lee are paying it forward
helping out in the store whatever he
needed me to do i was there so now i'm
like just answering the phones
directing people you know that come in
that need help
even though the upcoming labor day
weekend is an important one for the
furniture business
max says he's not going to kick anyone
out we're gonna keep these folks here as
long as they need to be here they may be
here
three days and may he be here seven who
knows we're here to help and that's what
we do that's who we are
for him to open his door
and said if you're affected by the flood
come in
and i mean you had people wet you had
people
dirty who does that do you have to see
it to believe it it's real
i mean he has a heart of gold just look
around us
a man is an angel
nobody asked him to do this the city
didn't call him and ask him if he could
open his doors mattress mac
said i want to and that's what thousands
of other people have done
brought their boats brought their
vehicles and their good hearts
and made people smile gail you know what
else made people smile yesterday at
about six o'clock
people were pulling over on the side of
the road to take a picture of the sun
something we hadn't seen here in about
three days
oh boy david what a great story listen
if you live in
houston it makes you think i want to go
to gallery furniture buy some furniture
and help some people out
go mattress max that's awesome thank you
david more perfect union indeed